and just have a look at the way that I'm
approaching it just so you know in your
hand on the right track so I've taken
one groups numbers and this is the
numbers that they the measurements they
gave me and so not knowing anything
about like the weird curvy bits and
other things on the diagrams right on
the field that you guys saw there if all
I had was these numbers then this is
really when I create up okay now by the
way can I just say yeah that's roughly
what I expected remember I said like
scale not to scale I've done my best
punches profit yes penny it's not
perfect but yeah this kinda is the shape
I was expecting now I've got two
questions to ask prove it off an area
that's all okay so let's tackle them one
at a time
I've got a whole bunch of lakes here
right it might be helpful if I gave
these things names so when you have a
polygon like this we tend to give all of
the quarters vertices capital minutes as
names so I call these a b c and e if i
want to prove it up then i'm going to
need to look at each of these legs
individually but thankfully and this is
the reason why the Traverse sara is the
way it is every one of those legs a b b
c CD etc then all in right legal
triangles they're all the hypotenuse of
a right angle trend so for instance if i
wanted to work out a beam I would say a
B Square is what if Pythagoras tell me
in that top my trains right so out of
that I'm going to add up whatever these
large numbers are I'm going to take the
square root of both sides and that's
gonna give me a number in fact I'm gonna
someone gonna beat me to actually
calculating what this number is someone
already got this
maybe the swimming weight have you taken
spirit can you take the square root of
that uh give me one okay now just have a
look is that cutting the bull pop you
expected yes it is right 87 meters I put
some coins you know that looks that
looks kind of right you can repeat this
process for each one of your banks and
you'll get a prove enough so once you've
got that I'd love you to make out what
your perimeter is and pump it up on the
board where I'm giving you a split how
about that area I'm kind of started
walking you through this before right I
can name these triangles right right hey
triangle right triangle I'm gonna call
that one a B C right maybe see what's
the formula for the area of a triangle
huh base times height now remembering
that my height here even though it's
sideways it has to be this one why does
it have to be that one
I'm here this triangle over here this
big one the way it started P it's
perpendicular right it's not just any
height it's the perpendicular height and
this is the only distance I have it's
perpendicular to a science so I'm gonna
go to this base which the field diagram
tells me sorry that the measurements
tell me is a hundred thirty one and then
I'm gonna go with the perpendicular
height which is 64 so I didn't know what
32 times a hundred thirty one of these
can someone tell me I'm gonna beat
someone to this one and then you can add
it all up that's just hot yeah